this is why
you have people in the popular culture
who are who you might not expect who are
questioning the narrative one of them is
Kyrie Irving I'm not uh not the biggest
basketball fan as you might know you
know not not the most athletic fella out
there Kyrie Irving I was just watching
his interview uh his press conference
and I expect the press to be talking
about basketball and stuff like that and
instead I find all the Press wants to
talk about is the fact that Kyrie Irving
posted
a generally innocuous
seemingly innocuous Alex Jones clip once
to his Instagram
okay while we're on the topic of
promotion
why did you decide to promote something
that Alex Jones said
that was a few weeks ago I do not stand
with Alex Jones
position narrative
court case that he had with Sandy Hook
or any of the kids that felt like they
had to relive trauma or parents that had
to relive trauma or to be dismissive to
all the lives that were lost during that
a tragic event
my my post was a post from Alex Jones
that he did in the early 90s or late 90s
about secret societies in America of
occults and it's true so I wasn't
identifying with anything of being a
campaign a campaignist for Alex Jones or
anything I'm just there to post and it's
funny
and it's actually hilarious because out
of all the things I posted that that was
the moan post that everyone chose to
chose to see it just goes back to the
way our world is and works I'm not here
to complain about it I just exist
and to follow up on the promotion of the
movie in the book can you please stop
calling her a promotion
it's the nice part of the this reporter
just keeps showing but why do you like
Alex Jones why are you promoting Alex
Jones why do you come on stop you can't
promote you can't talk about Alex Jones
you can't why why and Kyrie Irving is
saying look I know man I don't know
about the Sandy Hook thing or what I
don't care I'm not I'm not saying
anything about that I posted a clip from
30 Years Ago by the way here's the clip
faction common sense you're in and yes
there have been corrupt Empires yes they
manipulate yes there are secret
societies yes there have been
oligarchies throughout history and yes
today in 2002 there is a tyrannical
organization calling itself the New
World Order pushing for
worldwide government a cashless Society
total and complete tyranny by
centralizing and socializing Health Care
the state becomes God basically when it
comes to your health and then by
releasing diseases and viruses and
plagues upon us we then basically get
shoved into their system where human
beings are absolutely worthless that's
just true
that's just that's just a fact I mean
what's he saying there have been
oligarchies in history
people sometimes conspire in small
groups to seize power and there is a a
popular phrase called the new world
order that that certain people are
advocating for today we would probably
call that more the great reset but it's
the same thing you have very prominent
people using this phrase saying we need
a great reset we need a new world order
that's just a fact so why
even by the way so Kyrie Irving right
he's very quick to say I don't you're
trying to talk to me about a Sandy Hook
shooting on I have nothing I'm not
saying anything about that I obviously I
I think that's bad that he said that I'm
okay bad Alex Jones but what's your pro
why can't I post this clip about how
political power is often different than
it appears to be
what no you're not allowed to post that
I mean it makes you wonder the fact that
they're punishing Alex Jones this way
but you've now got a court order that
he'd pay upwards of a billion dollars
for getting a story wrong on the air
yes he got the story very wrong yes it
was horrible but he said yes he's the
worst person in the world okay fine sure
I mean let's let's just grant all that a
billion dollars for saying for getting a
story wrong on the air
followed by now the the demand for 2.75
trillion dollars it's just so bizarre
when you think that many other people in
our culture have said
way crazier things way way more harmful
things that have had much more of a
harmful effect in the real world I mean
just talk about what the kind of lies
and misinformation that went on during
covet from the libs who are now
demanding a truce and an amnesty and
pleading for it I mean those lies
resulted in much more actual real world
harm than anything that even Alex Jones
has said and sure he said totally wacky
okay sure fine but
in terms of real world harm it hasn't
been more harmful than what Anthony
fauci said hasn't been more harmful than
what Rachelle valenski said Joe Biden
said or any of these other people so why
do they go because
when when Kyrie Irving I haven't spoken
to him about this but when Kyrie Irving
sees
not the kind of multi-trillion dollar
requests billion dollar judgments
against someone for saying something
when when he's just being inundated at
his press conference by these questions
about this one random clip he posted
that was basically Anodyne in and of
itself
that is going to give him and other
people more reason to believe huh
maybe maybe there is a kind of oligarch
political power here I wasn't totally
convinced of it before but now
but now I wonder
conspiracy theories such as they are
grow
ing periods of a lack of trust in our
political institutions
and
that's not the end of the story
people lose trust in our institutions
because of corruption and conspiracy
that actually takes place we've got
we've got the evidence of it in black
and white
you know the corporate media agenda
means that the news is presented in a
biased way you know it I know it
everybody knows it thankfully there is a
way to get the most important news of
the day without their narrative that is
by listening to one of the top news
podcasts morning wire new episodes are
available every morning seven days a
week and they cover stories other media
Outlets won't touch every Sunday until
the midterm elections you can also tune
into election wire for in-depth coverage
candidate interviews and more it's the
most important midterm election in
recent history it's coming up soon
you'll want to be informed you will find
morning wire and election wire on Apple
podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
speaking of the deep State attacking
conservatives
Lee zeldin is uh he's the Republican
candidate for governor in New York and
all of a sudden he's under investigation
for Super PAC violations
areas being reported by the hill
Lee zeldin the Republican candidate for
Governor New York Senator investigation
by the State Board of Elections over
allegations that he coordinated with two
super Pacs supporting his campaign
what does this mean
according to our current
silly election laws
candidates can raise an unlimited amount
of money
that is people who support candidates
can donate an unlimited amount of money
to support that Canada but the election
laws for some stupid reason say you
can't donate the money directly to the
candidates campaign
you have to donate it to something
called a Super PAC which is a totally
separate group that according to the law
can have absolutely no coordination or
anything whatsoever with the campaign
now the Super PAC only exists to support
the candidate
or the some con men have exploited this
law to pretend they say I've got a Super
PAC I've got the new the new Super PAC
to support Donald Trump and they've
really never talked to Donald Trump and
they really have never coordinated with
Donald Trump and they really have no
intention of giving any money to help
Donald Trump they just use it to make
money for themselves and you saw a lot
of these crop up since this stupid Super
PAC
aspect of the law has gone into effect
but when it works perfectly the idea is
yes you've got two entities the campaign
pack and the Super PAC both of which are
designed to get this candidate elected
but they're not allowed to coordinate
with each other one little bit
so
that's the background did Lee zeldin
coordinate with his Super PAC I don't
know like maybe I don't even what does
that even mean was he at an event that
his Super PAC was also at
well that's true of every candidate of
both parties in the country that that
sort of has to happen because that's
where the that's where the action is
right that's where the that's what the
money is for
now is it that Lee zeldon or one of his
staff members uh coordinated on a TV
commercial or a mailer or I don't know I
don't know I don't really care I don't I
know the Democrats do this sort of thing
all the time and I know that New York is
one of the most corrupt states in the
country when it comes to the government
it's New York Illinois is really bad
about that California is not so hot
itself but New York in particular is
where Albany is really really corrupt
and so why are they doing this
now they're doing this of course because
Lee Selden is not supposed to be leading
in this race because New York's a
Democrat State and Kathy hokel is
supposed to glide into re-election
and that's that and the fact that the
people are now seem to be supporting Lee
zeldin that's a big problem
and so the the state the bureaucracy the
corrupt powers that be
going to have to come in and kind of
tilt that back for the Democrats would
you call that a conspiracy
if you talk about that would you call it
a conspiracy theory I guess so it's a
theory about a conspiracy but there's
some evidence for it
and especially in light of everything
else that we're learning now about how
the government is putting its thumb its
boot on the scales for the Democrats the
theory seems to have a fair bit of
credibility so we've got the love don't
judge challenge today
it's very spooky It's a Spooky post
Halloween love don't judge challenge uh
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss this if you are
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign